let's go next to
uh how about enrique from north carolina
you're on the air
hi david yes
it's outside and talking to you
please
so my question is do you know anything
about daca
the future is lighting up for that
no
i mean it's
i've been saying for a very long time
that there we need a permanent solution
when it comes to daca it just we just
need it it has to happen
but um i am not aware
i wish i could tell you i think it's
coming soon i don't really think it's
coming soon i don't not this year anyway
yeah are you you're you're a daca
recipient
uh yeah i was brought in here when i was
one year old
sorry you were born here or brought here
at one year old i miss that
oh i was
brought right here at one year old that
makes sense yeah most people are born at
zero not at one i figured i misheard
oh yeah
and how old are you now
uh i'm 21 now wow so this is this is
really your country
oh yeah i mean i know more
i'm more american than i am that's
right i love i love you know mexican
culture but
i i grew up in american culture you know
i speak english i'm just as american as
anyone else here for sure
yeah i mean if if if someone came to you
and said sir you've got to go back to
mexico
i can only imagine how devastating that
would be
i'll all will be freaking out i don't
know what i would do yeah
yeah well listen i'm with you we need a
solution i hope that that we get to it
sooner than later but
realistically it doesn't seem like
there's a political appetite to get it
done this this year at minimum
now
all right thank you david
my pleasure thank you so much for
calling in
yeah i mean uh you know millions of
people in that situation millions
millions
um
is it millions maybe it's not now i
misremember is it hundreds of thousands
many people many people
let's go next to
josie from michigan
josie you're on the air
what's up david how are you doing how
you doing
good i just wanted to know um what do
you think about the 30 u.s school
children still stuck in afghanistan
right now i'm not aware of the number of
people left what what are the
circumstances were they on like a some
kind of summer trip or something believe
it or not um they were on a school trip
i don't know who takes their
school children to afghanistan that's my
question i mean it's it's now i know
that sometimes when people say
how on earth would you take kids people
come back and say there's much to learn
culturally historically i i don't deny
that i don't deny that i just don't
understand
given the security situation who who
would do that what age kids are they are
they high schoolers do you know
uh i think i heard something along the
lines of one of the principal or one of
the students dad is a us official or
something like that and they were going
no have they do we know i don't know
anything about this story have joe
biden's administration has said anyone
who wants to get out we will help get
out there's no time limit on it like are
they are is there is this in the middle
of a process or what's going on yeah
it's really hard to find information on
at this point because even if you google
it at this point it only shows articles
up till like september 3rd and then
there's been no word on it since it's
been mentioned really is it possible
they got out but there just haven't been
articles written because there's less of
a story once they're just back in the us
that's possible i don't know i just
thought it would be it was worthy you
would think you would think
i mean listen like i've said before
we've got to support everybody who wants
to get out joe biden said there's no
time limit if you don't want to get out
now and then in a month you do he says
the u.s will help and do everything that
the government can so let's hope they
stick to it
yeah let's hope all right good talking
to you david my pleasure thanks for the
call there's josie from michigan
um a lot of a lot of good questions
today let's try a different country just
for kicks how about fiona from germany
fiona you're on the air
hello
i will
thought about the afghanistan topic
again and we have data on how much
civilian support staff has been working
with the military but
the data has been collected by civilian
organizations and only made available to
government or listened to by the
government
as recently as like the 10th of
september and i would like to know the
american situation do you think that
would be listened to if a civilian
organization would like mention civilian
support staff that may or may not be
interested in leaving afghanistan and if
so would there be assistance rendered
i i apologize i'm not sure i understand
the question you're saying
american civilian support staff
currently in afghanistan is that who
we're talking about no uh civilian
afghan support staff that happen to
support european troops
is also being evacuated in a very very
small situation and share
are you listening to some video in the
background i just heard someone say hi
how are you
no oh that was weird
um
i don't know i mean i don't know if they
would qualify for asylum or refugee
status i'm just not sure uh
it's very hard for me to answer that
question i i just don't know yeah it's a
convoluted thing yeah it's just popped
in my mind but thank you for calling on
me oh no problem how are things in
germany are okay
they have been very good yeah excellent
i spent 24 hours there last month and it
was fantastic
well
that's nice to hear yeah i hope to be
back any of the political campaigning
in germany no i have not no idea
it was very startling to be when it
appeared and it was so tiny and small
you didn't see that other countries yeah
no that's for sure all right thank you
so much for the call
goodbye okay very good